but first with just hours of course
until the first polling place is open
president trump as you can see look at
him he's just
still working hard for your vote in fact
the president
still rallying the faithful in kenosha
wisconsin with
a fifth rally to come a little bit later
on
uh tonight we hope in the show the man
is an absolute machine
breakneck schedule it's emblematic of
how he's been running the country for
the last four years
and it reminds me of why the people
elected him in the first place
and it's paying off now check out the
real clear politics polling averages in
the key swing states
trump's ahead in five of them and is
within striking distance in the other
three
he sweeps all eight and he wins
now when the president left the hospital
remember after his covet diagnosis four
weeks ago
all the experts in the on the left in
the media and democrat politics
said don't campaign it's too dangerous
you'll be a super spreader
told him not to hold rallies but he knew
how
this was the most important election of
our lifetime
and how important his campaigning was
for the psyche of america
he had to be with the people they had to
see him he knew it was important for
americans
not to succumb to the media and the
biden
doom and gloom propaganda they've been
pushing on you
since the beginning of this pandemic and
the president's fans
well what did they do his supporters the
voters they repaid him
by turning out in the cold in the uh in
the rain in the heat
in the wind for rallies and impromptu
caravans this was all organic in
arizona 1500 cars took part in a
pro-trump parade
that stretched for miles and miles
conservatives in san diego put on a huge
boat parade a liberal sea of trump
supporters
tens of thousands turned out last
weekend in butler pennsylvania
i personally shot this video in overflow
crowd in rochester minnesota
and then check out these crowds last
night this is in
rome georgia check it out then miami of
course
this was the scene it was a massive
party there and here's trump in traverse
city michigan
earlier tonight again huge crowds
that crow just goes on forever and ever
again organic
oh this is an organic movement it's a
love for this president
meanwhile the favorite candidate of
china silicon valley
and wall street is out ranting on the
trail
and being propped up by the same
out-of-touch forces
that failed hillary in 2016.
i work for lady gaga no other nation can
touch us
everybody knows who donald trump is we
choose
truth over lies constant lies donald
trump's not strong he's weak
we choose truth over lies
gosh she doesn't seem so confident to me
now you compare that
to trump's final rallying cry for him
it's about the people
even more so than about biden
do you want to be ruled by the arrogant
corrupt ruthless and
selfless political class or do you want
to be governed by
the american people themselves
we will never be a socialist nation and
that's what they're trying to do
if i don't always play by the rules of
washington and the washington
establishment
it's because i was elected to fight for
you and i fight harder
and harder and harder
[Applause]
and that is true for months we've been
told that lightning can't strike twice
but of course the media on the left are
missing
what's happening the nature of what
we're seeing
the crowds the pop-up caravans
look at it in boat parades the passion
i've never seen boat parades when did
that start
they're all happening whether the media
reports about it or not
and whether the left believes it or not
and whatever happens tomorrow night one
thing is completely clear
this movement this america first
movement is
here and it ain't going anywhere